A different person. I had a second opinion appointment today with the head neck surgeon for my HP HPV positive squamous cell cancer on my tonsil.
He also said that surgery was not an option and he would immediately put it a feeding to because I am malnourished. I've lost almost 40 pounds.
Well, you don't want to be in a state of caquexia. So a feeding to can have its benefits to get food in you so that you're not continuing to lose weight and a feeding tube is not doesn't that it will not be permanent.
My new oncologist mentioned to be a therapy working for this cancer, but that was before today's news and I don't know what he'll say about the surgeon's evaluation.
So immunotherapy is completely different than surgery immunotherapy is a drug IV drip.
That remember has blocks the pretty for receptor on the T cell so that it will help stimulate immune response against the cancer.
So if the surgeon said surgery is not an option, I don't think that has anything to do with the immunotherapy being an option or not. So the immunotherapy is an option that might be a good option to take.
I know they use a lot of sugar and feedings will know feeding to you are putting your food in your feeding to me to use their prepared stuff.
Kate farms uses a prepared food for feeding to you can get it from there.
People have made their own peg food feeding food with like greens first and protein powders and different things like that you can make that yourself.
And I'm out of fact I think we have a recipe on the blog post if you look for peg food feeding to recipes we have one of our blog posts you can make your own stuff.
I could choose the chemo drugs are there any better than others to request again I'm not a specialist in chemo drugs you have to refer to what you're oncologist is recommended.
And if immunotherapy is something that they say works for you you have to have a certain gene type to be able to use immunotherapy they would test you for that.
That might be your better option.
Is there anything else I could be asking about treatment options to mitigate the side effects are damaged to your body if you're I'm assuming using immunotherapy you have to you have to treat the side effects as they come with immunotherapy because immunotherapy will decrease your your T cells response to all your cells.
And you can end up with different inflammatory states most commonly like colitis and things you have to treat it as they come up what should I ask my next cheek swab.
Well, the right update.
You can ask you can just put your questions when you have things like this put all those questions that you have in your cheek swab request form so that we can get to the bottom of this as best we can do you not understand I can only do so much I don't know everything I'm not your healer God is your healer my role is to to guide you in nutrition and frequency use.
And I can't tell you medical answers.